-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from the hit show
"The Summer I Turned Pretty."
She's making her Broadway debut
in "Hadestown,"
February 9th through March 17th.
Please welcome to the show
Lola Tung, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
-Welcome to the show, Lola!
-[ Chuckles ]
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
-This is your
"Late Night" debut.
We're so honored
to be sharing it with you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Wow. Yeah.
I'm thrilled to be here.
-So,
"The Summer I Turned Pretty" --
a massively popular show.
Congratulations on its success.
Also, your first acting credit.
That seems very surreal to me.
I can only imagine
how it feels to you.
-Yeah, I mean, it's wild,
and I can't even believe it.
But, I mean, you know,
I did my fair share
of high school
and middle school theater.
So, you know, it's been
a long road, but, yeah.
-What was your biggest role
in middle school?
-Um, okay.
I had a -- I was the Tin Man
in "The Wizard of Oz."
That's my first one.
-That's huge. Yeah.
How -- Looking back,
do you feel like
the costume was well made?
-Oh, I mean, I think I,
like, thrifted the jacket,
and then I got some
silver rain boots.
-Gotcha. But it was enough.
You felt like
you could act in it.
-Oh, absolutely.
-Okay, good, good, good.
-Best ones are homemade.
-I like that I thought
someone else would make it.
I forgot,
middle school productions,
you literally came home and
you're like, "I got good news.
You're making me a costume."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, my mom was --
My mom was very supportive.
-Alright, that's good.
And then what about high school?
-Um, high school was, uh --
I didn't do as many shows.
It was more like classes
and scenes.
And I was studying drama
in high school, so, um...
I was, uh, Apostle Number 9
in "Jesus Christ Superstar."
-Alright!
-That was a good one.
That's my favorite of
the apostles in that show.
-Thank you.
Yeah, it was a big one.
-And you, uh -- you were then
at Carnegie Mellon in Pittsburgh
when you got cast in this,
and you were also going
to acting school in college
during the pandemic.
So that meant masks,
which I'm wondering
what it was like,
being a student
doing acting with scene mates,
and you were all in masks.
-Yeah, I mean,
half of it was, like,
a lot of eye-contact work,
which is super fun.
[ Laughter ]
And then we did scenes
on Zoom.
So I was in -- at home
in my living room,
and my sister was on her online
classes in the other room,
and I was, like, screaming
into the computer screen
at my -- at my classmates.
So that was...
-It's funny, I feel
like the pandemic was hard
for anybody who was studying,
but I do feel for your sister,
'cause I would imagine
the hardest is
when your a family member
is a Zoom acting class.
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure.
-Full emoting.
-Yeah.
-So, this show, again,
so popular, so fast.
When did you start noticing
that it was a show
people were watching?
When did people
start approaching you?
-I mean, um, yeah --
Well, I mean,
a couple days
after the show came out,
I went to a Yankee game
with a couple of my castmates.
I'm a Mets fan, I'm not...
-Okay, gotcha.
-Putting that out there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Um, but, um,
we went to the game,
and I remember, like,
just being stared at
a lot more than normal.
Like, nobody --
I mean, I never --
You know what I mean?
-Right,
-You know what I mean.
And then, like,
seeing pictures on the Internet
that I didn't know were taken
from afar of, you know --
of just all of us hanging out.
And I was like, "Oh, man,
this is -- this is
a drawing attention, I guess.
But I'm so happy
that the people love it."
-I would imagine,
when you first saw the part,
when you first read the script,
it must have felt like,
"Oh, this is such a cool part,
such a cool show."
You must have been
so excited
when you found out
you got it.
-Yeah, I totally was.
And I mean, I wasn't --
I was in school
and kind of just
was like, "This is my path."
So it was cool to just have
a little, um --
be a little spontaneous
and have this --
this really amazing curveball
thrown my way.
-You had a very
baller celebration
when you found out
you got this.
-Yes.
-What did you do?
Tell everybody,
because it is exactly
what I would do
if I got a huge part.
-Okay, I'm glad. I mean,
it's the only thing to do.
My roommates came home,
and we all made dinner
and watched "Zootopia."
-Yeah.
-That was...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Shout-out to them.
-That's how you do it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was awesome.
-You probably called them
and are like, "You guys
want to watch 'Zootopia'?"
And they were like,
"What happened?
What are we celebrating?"
-We do it for all events.
All -- All exciting moments.
-So, you -- you went viral
on TikTok
with an answer to a question,
which I, watching it,
it's just you
authentically reacting.
And were you surprised
that this became something
that then had,
I guess, an online moment?
-Absolutely.
I mean, I feel like
you can't ever
really predict what goes viral.
And I was just excited
about -- about a question.
-You were excited
about a question.
First, I'm gonna show everybody,
in case they haven't seen it.
Here's your reaction
to a question
that everybody was very taken
with your reaction.
-Yes.
[ Gasps ] Oh, my goodness,
I love this question!
Um, I think...
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
I will say, I watched that,
and I'm like,
"Oh, that is very endearing."
-[ Laughs ] Thank you.
-It's really fun.
Also, by the way,
I've done this show
almost 1,500 times.
I've never asked a guest
a question
where they've reacted that way.
[ Laughter ]
I really feel like
I have to up my question game.
-It was a question
about Taylor Swift music.
So, you know, I mean,
I was very enthusiastic, but...
-But then other people --
Olivia Rodrigo,
Scarlett Johansson,
among others --
have then basically
used it to lip-synch.
Let's take a couple
of looks at those.
-[ Gasps ] Oh, my goodness,
I love this question!
Um, I think...
-[ Gasps ] Oh, my goodness,
I love this question!
Um, I think...
[ Laughter ]
-So...
what was it like
when you first started seeing
that other people
were using your answer?
-I was like,
"Oh, this is so cute."
And then it's, like,
kinda weird to hear your voice
coming out of
Scarlett Johansson's mouth.
But super cool, so thanks.
Thanks, you guys.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you now,
when you get asked questions,
do you feel,
like, a real pressure
to have a reaction to it?
-Well, I wasn't,
but maybe now I do.
I'm like, "Oh."
[ Laughter ]
-I don't want to
put you in your head.
but this next question I'm gonna
ask is really [bleep] good.
Um, do you want to have
anything prepared?
It's really good. No.
So, we mentioned
your middle school and
high school stage work.
And now you're gonna do
"Hadestown" on Broadway.
How does it feel
to return to stage?
-It's, like,
the best feeling ever.
I mean, it's, you know,
where I fell in love
with acting and all that,
so it's -- I'm so excited.
-And so what process are you --
obviously, the show
is up and running right now.
So, what is the process
for someone like you,
who's stepping into the role?
Like, what are rehearsals?
-Um, it's, uh,
working with, like,
the dance captain
and the directors
and a bunch
of the amazing swings.
And then I'm also
in rehearsal with Ani DiFranco,
who's stepping into Persephone
really soon --
one of the other roles
in the show.
And that's been, like,
the coolest thing ever,
'cause she's awesome.
And, um,
I'm just having a blast.
I mean, it's like
we've learned the show
and we've done it
a couple times,
so it's starting
to feel -- feel real.
-And when you now
have access, obviously,
to maybe a slightly better,
if not free, discounted tickets,
are family and friends
coming out of the --
Are they like,
"Don't forget me, Lola.
I watched 'Zootopia' with you.
You owe me."
-[ Laughs ]
It's funny 'cause I, you know,
I mean, I think most of
my friends and family
were very quick to jump
to buy tickets
when the announcement came out,
so I'm grateful for that.
A lot of people
are coming to see it.
Some of my college friends.
So, yeah, I'm super excited
that they can be there.
-It's really wonderful.
Congratulations on all
your success, the show,
and I'm looking forward
to you in "Hadestown."
Break a leg out there.
-Thank you so much.
-Lola Tung, everybody.
You can see her in "Hadestown"
on Broadway,
February 9th through March 17th.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."